The broadcast is now starting. All
attendees are in listen only mode. Hey,
good morning everybody. It's Thursday,
September 15th, 2022. Hope everyone is
doing well. You know, it's been an
interesting week so far in the markets.
And
you know, it's it's always fascinating
because you know, the markets is really
a collection of you know, people's
thoughts and um honestly predictions,
you know, but they're
what they're expecting the market to do,
you know, and up until a couple of days
ago, you know, everyone thought we were
going to start rallying again, but
obviously the inflation numbers came out
and the market sold off. And again,
today the market again is is still
feeling that selling pressure. And
what I'm going to talk about today is
how to discover new trading strategies
with order flow. And you know, we all
know that you know, in trading, you
know, we always want to have
an edge, okay? And
fortunately for us, we live in an
information age. And there's just a lot
of information out there that can help a
trader. And honestly, it is overwhelming
trying to sift through it all and figure
out what's relevant to you and your
trading style. And that's why I'm glad
you took the time to join me today for
this quick training session. Now, what
you're going to learn today is you're
going to learn about order flow and how
it affects the market.
You're going to learn how to leverage
that order flow data to uncover hidden
trading opportunities. And I'll show you
how to profit from understanding how
orders move market prices. Now, for
those of you that are new to one of my
presentations, my name is Michael Valtos
and I've got over 25 years of
professional trading experience. You
know, I started on the Chicago
Mercantile Exchange trading floor as a
runner. I started literally at the
bottom of the industry.
And I worked my way up over the years. I
left the floor
when electronic trading started taking
off. I was working for Dean Witter at
the time and they needed, you know, what
what was called the Globex operator.
That was what the overnight session was
called. And, you know, I said, "Hey, you
know what? I I was in my 20s at the time
and you know, I
interested in computers and it was
computerized trading. That was the
beginning.
So, I took the opportunity to leave the
trading floor and work up on their
off-the-floor trading desk. And
unfortunately, at that time there was no
such thing as side-by-side trading. So,
to
trade those markets, you had to work the
night shift. And I ended up working the
night shift for,
you know, almost 10 years. And you know,
I I enjoyed it actually. You don't have
to deal with the office politics. After
about 3 years with Dean Witter, I left
to join EDF Man, the big English trading
company, um in Chicago,
on their global macro futures trading
desk.
After that, I joined Commerzbank, also
in Chicago. I was a licensed I became a
licensed Eurex trader there. I was only
at that time, back in the '90s, I was
only one of about 10 people outside of
Germany that was allowed to trade uh
German bonds, DAX, Euro stocks, etc. on
the exchange provided trading system.
After September 11th, you know, I took
about 6 months off, traveled the world,
you know,
trying to get my priorities straight.
Then I joined Cargill,
um in Chicago. Cargill's a big commodity
trading firm. It's a privately held
company, but if it was a publicly held
company, it would probably be the the
first or second largest company in the
United States. You know, they provide
about 20
5% of meat exports, about 35% of grain
exports. I was I ran their trading desk
in Chicago. And when the exchange in
Singapore closed down, they sent me out
to Singapore to set up an off-the-floor
trading desk.
In about 2005, 2006, I left Cargill and
I joined JP Morgan. I was vice president
of futures trading in Singapore. I spent
uh
8 years there, 8 or 9 years. And after I
got married, had my first kid, I decided
to you know what? There's more to life
than working um 12 hours a day
at JP Morgan, you know, coming in and
just spending more time in the office
than at home and I left to trade for
myself. And eventually I started up in
2015, orderflows.com
which is uh an order flow uh education
company and a trading software. And I've
been doing that since 2015 and you know,
it's going on 7 8 years already. So,
the reason I talk about my background is
because, you know, I've traded a very
high level and
I understand how order flow works,
right? Because I was a lot of that order
flow, right? I I was a size trader and I
saw what my orders can do to the market,
the effects that it has on other traders
that are out there, you know, just
you know, trying to survive, trade for
their own retail accounts. And then I
saw how my big orders could come in and
influence the market. And now, what I've
done is I've taken a lot of that
information that I've gained over the
years and I've tried to put it into
software
for retail traders. Now, I'm a retail
trader. I don't consider myself a
professional trader because, you know, I
just trade for my own account.
And
you know, sort of I want to level that
playing field. I want to make it easier
for
the smaller traders to understand what's
really happening in the soft in in the
market by having software that is going
to help debunk what they're looking at
in the market. Now,
the charts and the tools that I use in
this training are generated for my order
flow software. But honestly, what I'm
showing you today can be applied with
other order flow footprint software as
long as you know what to look for. You
know, there's there's my software that
runs on NinjaTrader 8, there's Sierra
Charts, you know, there's MotiveWave,
there's a lot of software out there,
okay? But to be honest, unless you know
what to look for and more importantly
know how to use the software that you
have, it's it's kind of pointless to
trade with order flow. So, that's why I
enjoy doing these trainings is so you
can learn
what to look for, you know, I cuz I get
emails all the time for people saying,
you know, even people that don't use my
software. You know, they might, you
know, you
Thanks for making this video or doing
this training because now I understand
what's happening in the market. And
really, you want to be able to see how
easily and quickly you can apply order
flow analysis to your trading
to make better trades. So, before we
jump in, you know, brief disclaimer, you
know, trading does involve risks, right?
The risk capital is money that could be
lost without jeopardizing your financial
security or lifestyle. And only trade
with risk capital you can afford to
lose. So, when it comes to trading,
every little edge is going to make a big
difference. That's why I'm always on the
lookout for new ways to get an edge on
the competition. And one tool that I
found very useful is order flow trading.
Right? And this goes back to my days on
the floor when you're there was a
trading floor, you could see what the
order flow is coming in. Once it went
electronic, it was anonymous. All right,
you can't see who the big buyer is or
who the big seller is. You could see the
trades taking place. And you got to
start, you know, reverse engineering and
put it together what's really happening
in the market.
But once you understand order flow,
you're able to make better informed
trading decisions.
So, remember, order flow is all about
understanding how orders are being
traded, right? By tracking these trades,
you get a feel for the market sentiment
and you're going to make better trading
decisions.
Now, order flow is not easy. Trading is
not easy. But it order flow is a tool
that's going to give you an advantage
in the market, right? And you want to
have an edge over everybody else. Now,
the first thing I'll talk about is
order flow and how it affects the
markets, okay? So,
order flow is simply a way to organize
the trades that happen in the market.
Now, every trade that happens shows up
in the time and sales. This is what the
time and sales on on most uh trading
platforms look like, right? You see the
time, you see the trade that went
through, you see the quantity.
Right? Now, you'll notice there's
there's different colors, right? Cuz
some trades are happening on the bid,
some trades are happening on the offer,
right? A market
always trade in a two-way auction.
There's always a bid, there's always an
offer.
So, there are traders bidding and
there's traders offering. There's people
sitting on a bid, whether it's, you
know, if it's five bid at six,
there's bidders sitting at five. They're
happy to buy at five. They don't want to
go chase the market. They don't want to
pay six. They think the market is worth
five. Then you have sellers offering at
six.
Those are the offers. Those are passive
sellers.
They are
in their mind they think the market is
worth six. So, they don't want to sell
it at five, they want to sell it at six.
Okay? Now, bids and offers by themselves
don't cause a market to move.
Right? You need some
trading that's going to take place. And
there needs to be aggressive traders,
traders who cross that bid offer to get
a trade done. Traders who buy the offer
or sell into the bid, those are called
aggressive traders. And think of it like
this.
You know, recently I had to buy a a car,
okay? Another car. And, you know, there
there's a car that I like. I went to the
dealer. The car's listed at, you know,
the price 35,000.
Okay? Well, that's what the dealer would
love to sell it at. He's a passive
seller at 35,000.
Now, you know, maybe I don't want to pay
35,000. I want to pay 30,000. So, my bid
is 30,000. The dealer's offer is 35,000.
So, I'm a passive buyer at 30. He's a
passive seller at 35. Yeah, I I
you know,
I like this car, but, you know,
all I want to spend is 30,000. So,
for me to buy the car, the
dealer would have to get aggressive,
lower his price, sell it to me at
30,000. Now, if it was a situation where
it's like, oh, you know, I really need
this car because
I got no transportation. And the dealer
says, "Oh, the price is 35,000. You
know, I'm firm." Okay, well, for me to
get the car, I got to pay 35,000. I'd
have to be the aggressive uh participant
in that case.
So, you know, think of it that way,
right? There's always a bid, there's
always an offer. The person that crosses
the bid offer
is the aggressor, okay? Now, by tracking
the order flow, a trader is able to see
which way the market is moving because
you'll be watching
which way the aggressive trading is
taking place. And well, that's what you
want to look for, right? Is you want to
look for the direction the aggressive
traders are trading. Now, there's again,
it's a two-way auction and there's
always aggressive buying and aggressive
selling. Really, what you're looking for
is the more aggressive buying than
aggressive selling. That's what's going
to cause the market to move up or down.
It's not that, you know, for every buyer
there's a seller.
What you're trying to look for is the
aggressive buyers outnumbering the
aggressive sellers.
So, on a DOM, right? This is your depth
of market, your price ladder.
Passive sellers are people working the
offers at the offer price and above.
Passive buyers are people that work the
bid price and below.
Passive traders are willing to wait for
the market to come to them, right?
They're happy, you know, if the market's
trading 39.53 and a half,
they think it's worth 52 and a half,
they're happy to throw in a bid here,
wait for the market to come to them,
right? They don't want to pay 54, they
don't want to pay 55, they want to pay
52 and a half. They're passive. They're
waiting for the market to come to them.
If the market starts moving down,
then, you know, aggressive traders are
selling the bids,
taking it out, turning it, you know,
offers are coming in, hitting the next
bid, hitting the next bid, before
finally that passive buyer gets filled.
Because the aggressive sellers
have taken over and cleared out all the
the passive bids there as the market
moves down. The aggressive traders cross
the bid offer line. They hit the bid or
lift the offer.
Now,
what the order flow chart does is it
takes all that information that's
happening in the time and sales, right?
All this information right in here. You
see the the green numbers, the
quantities, the red orange prices and
quantities, and it puts it into a nice
easy-to-read format. So, you can see how
much volume traded on the offer at a
price, how much volume traded on the bid
at a price.
So, when you format the data into an
order flow footprint chart, you can see
not only the volume traded in the
two-way auction, but you can determine
the aggression
that's taking place or not taking place,
right? Cuz just because, you know, we
talk about aggression, doesn't mean
there's always aggressive trading in the
market. You know, a lot of times the
market is just doing what it's doing.
It's just facilitating trade.
Now, most traders, you know, we start at
a normal candlestick chart, but
candlestick charts are tend to be
misleading because, you know, people
would like to say, "Well, you know,
because it's
green and red, oh yeah, I can see I can
see order flow." Well, no, all you're
really looking at is the open, the high,
the low, the close. I mean, they have
what they call wicks, which is these
little parts above or below a candle,
you know, which is the difference
between the high and the
the open or the low
and the open or the low and the close.
And, you know, if everyone think, "Oh,
I'm looking at order flow." Well, you're
you're not. You're just looking at
price, really. That's all you're doing
because you don't have volume,
you don't have
whether the transactions are taking
place on the bid or on the offer. So,
what you're doing with
order flow, again, you're taking all
this information that comes through on
the time and sales.
Price, obviously time,
the volume,
and more importantly, whether it's
trading on the bid or the offer. And
again, on a candlestick chart, where is
that information? It's not there. It
just It just doesn't exist. So, from the
time and sales,
once you put it into a footprint,
you're going to get a lot more
information that you can analyze. You're
going to get delta. Right? Delta is the
difference between aggressive buyers and
aggressive sellers in a bar. You have
max delta, which is the strongest
aggressive buyers were in a bar. You
have min delta, which is the strongest
aggressive sellers were in a bar.
Cumulative delta, which is the net
uh
delta, which is, you know, a measurement
of aggressive buying or aggressive
selling for the day, cuz it's
cumulative. So, you're starting it from
a point.
You have point of control.
Right? The which is the price level in a
bar with the most volume. And you have
imbalances, right? Which is telling you,
you know, when aggressive trading is out
of balance, right? So, when you have
more aggressive trading than more
aggressive buying than aggressive
selling by a certain percentage, which
I'm going to talk about later, that's
what you'd call a buying imbalance. If
you have more aggressive selling than
aggressive buying by a certain
percentage, you'd call that a selling
imbalance.
Now, the best part of order flow is
you're using data generated from the
trading that's taking place in the
market right now.
It's not based off of, you know, a a
200-period moving average, where you're
going back 200 periods for it.
You You You're making trading decisions
based off of what is happening right
now.
So, what you want to do is you want to
use this information
because it adds value to your trading.
So, what do you think is going to be
more useful? Just knowing the open, the
high, the low, and the close of a bar,
or knowing where and when aggressive
trading is taking place? So, on a
footprint chart, it's very
basic stuff, right? You're going to
learn You're You're going to look at it
at the end of the day and say, "You know
what? That's not that complicated.
So, here's S&P's, right? We're selling
off, then we rally, a nice V-shape. And
it's it's simple, right? Market is going
down, lower, lower, lower. It's got
negative deltas, right? Aggressive
sellers are in control.
Then the market starts rallying,
positive delta, right? Boom, boom, boom.
You even have
blue numbers in the bar, which is our
imbalances.
Buying imbalances on the way up,
selling imbalances on the way down.
Point of controls, right? The price
level in the bar with the most volume
are going lower as the market's going
lower. They're going higher as the
markets go up, right? Volume, right?
This is, you know, Granville 101.
You know, markets move on heavier
volume, right? They move directionally.
They go up. Now, a sign of a nice trend
up is higher prices on higher volume.
And if the volume is migrating higher in
each bar, in each period, whether it's a
1-minute bar or a
you know, a a 5,000 volume bar or a
30-minute bar, you know, you want to see
the volume in the bar transacting at
higher prices.
So, the easiest way to determine the
aggressiveness in the market is to look
at delta.
Okay? And
this is yesterday, right? We're at the
high of the day up here, 3981 and a
quarter. And what do you see? Right?
Looking at the delta, we're at the high
of the day, I'm seeing negative delta.
Right? We're coming up into the high,
even got negative delta. So, it's
telling me that there's aggressive
sellers up here at the high of the day.
Now, what do you think that information
is
telling you? Well, it's telling you to
get short, right? Because it's telling
you that at the high, right now, when
we're trading up here,
right? As this bar is forming, you see
the delta forming in real time,
you see the negative delta. Even the
next bar, more negative delta.
Right? So, you know, you're like, okay.
We're at the high. Are we going to go
higher or we going to reverse?
Well, if you see a lot of selling coming
in, aggressive selling coming in at the
high of the day, chances are it's going
to reverse.
Just as when we're at the low yesterday,
we hit 3929, and then the market rallied
up off that. You know, rallied
20 points.
But what was happening at the low of the
day?
Positive delta, aggressive buying
started appearing.
Okay, you're at your low of the day.
You've been You just sold off from, you
know, 3981 down to 3929.
What is that? 50 points?
And then you've seen nice aggressive
buying coming in, positive delta,
positive delta, positive delta right at
the low of the day.
Market's screaming to you
that this is your buying opportunity.
Okay? So, again, it's it's sometimes
it's just so obvious, right? This is
um earlier in the week in the S&P's.
Okay? We we could put this little bit of
a rally in.
You know, it's from 4124 all the way up
to 4133, and then we just go sideways.
As we're going sideways,
what's happening? You have negative
delta all coming in here. You got one
bar, two bars, three bars, four bars,
five bars, six bars before the market
drops back down into the 24s.
And this is something that's important
is
this market is going up,
right? You got the aggressive buying.
Now it's just going sideways. Okay? One,
it's not going up anymore, and two, you
have aggressive selling.
Okay? So, one, if it's not going up
anymore and it's going sideways, and
two, you're seeing aggressive selling
coming in,
what's the third option? The market's
going to go down because the market,
one, is not going up anymore, two, as
it's just sort of paused here, you have
aggressive selling coming in.
That just leaves option three cuz is not
going up, two is just going sideways,
three
you got aggressive selling. Finally, you
know, you put enough stuff on on the the
cart, it's going to fall over, and it
does, right? It falls right back a quick
um you know, 6 7
points
in a few bars.
This is also S&P's. You know, S&P's a
wild week so far in S&P's.
Today is no different. This was um on
the 12th, I think the 12th was Monday,
right? We're going up, making new highs,
negative delta.
All right? You got a new high by two
ticks, right? Go sideways, new high by
two ticks, negative delta, negative
delta, negative delta. Even in here,
negative delta. You hit the high, you
start to come off, go sideways, more
selling.
Right? So, imagine you're going up to
the high,
and all of a sudden, what do you see?
You're seeing aggressive sellers coming
out of the woodwork.
Well, if if that's not a a sign to you
that you should be getting short, I
don't know I really I I don't know if
you should
be trading, you know, because the market
is just telling you you got to get
short.
Right? The the trade is to the downside,
not to the upside. Now, if it was going
sideways like this, and all of a sudden
you started seeing some nice positive
deltas coming in, yeah, chances are we'd
go higher. But instead, you're seeing
negative deltas coming in. You're seeing
the aggressive selling coming in. So,
chances are for the move to go down.
So, that's how you can use aggressive
traders
to determine, you know, market
direction.
Now,
put the odds in your favor, right?
That's that's the famous line from uh
what was it?
Mockingjay, whatever. You know, may the
odds forever be in your favor. And in
trading, it's the same way. You know,
you want to leverage the order order
data to find those trading opportunities
that nobody else sees. And again, we're
always looking for edges in the markets.
And there's many different ways to get
an edge in trading. One way is to
recognize changes in the order flow.
When there's a shift in the order flow,
it can signal a change in conditions
that can be exploited
you know, for profit, basically. I don't
like to use the term profit cuz, you
know, I I don't want people thinking,
"Oh, you know, this is the holy grail."
No, I mean, there's still work you have
to you still got to think about what
you're doing in your trading,
but you know, order flow shows you
shifts in market sentiment so you could
take advantage of them.
Cuz at the end of the day, order flow is
what causes what creates price movement.
Markets go from balance to imbalance
back to balance. And it's when markets
are out of balance that trading
opportunities happen.
Okay, so remember I told you market
generated information that comes from
order flows, delta, max delta, min
delta, point of control, imbalances,
value areas.
But what I'm going to talk about now is
imbalances, okay? So an imbalance occurs
when
in the two-way auction, you have more
aggressive buying than aggressive
selling
by a certain ratio. So
a buying imbalance would be when you
have four times as many aggressive
buyers than aggressive sellers. Meaning
in the two-way auction, the market is
five bid at six, 100 uh
trades on the offer at six, but only 20
trade on the bid at five. So you know,
20 into
100, right? It's a difference of five to
one. So you have an imbalance there.
That would be considered a buying
imbalance. A selling imbalance would be,
you know, the opposite. If you had 100
traded on the bid, but only 20 traded on
the offer, that would be considered a
selling imbalance. And when they come in
and where they come in are important to
us as traders.
So you can see here, right? Market sold
off and the market shot right back up.
As it's shooting back up, all the blue
numbers inside of the bar
are buying imbalances. Red numbers
are selling imbalances. This the black
volumes is just your normal order flow,
right? There's nothing out of balance
there. But when you're starting to see
big areas of imbalances come in,
that's a sign to you that, you know
what? Trading is activity has picked up.
There's an aggressive trader in the
market.
You probably want to be
not fighting that big aggressive trader,
right? You probably, at a minimum, want
to be going with him.
And you'll notice, as well,
some bars have stacked imbalances. This
is a stacked imbalance here. They got a
little stacked imbalance here. But other
bars also have buying imbalances, but
sometimes they're spread out. Now,
stacked imbalances are easy to see in a
bar because they're nice and neat
grouped together. They're in a nice
little cluster, so to speak.
But bars that have
multiple imbalances that are spread out,
it's a little bit harder to see.
And if you have trading software, it can
highlight that to you. So, you could see
in in this red bar here, there's
1 2 3 4 selling imbalances. Now, they're
it's not stacked They're not stacked
neatly on top of each other. They're
spread out in the bar.
So, you know that there's
aggressive selling, but it's a little
spread out in the bar. But it's still
aggressive selling. It's still
information that you want to use in your
trading.
Market sells off again. Another bar with
aggressive selling spread out in the
bar. They're not stacked. This is a
stacked buying imbalance in here. This
one in here is stacked buying imbalance.
But here you got, you know, one price
with an imbalance, then a regular order
flow, another imbalance, another regular
price with regular order flow, another
imbalance, another imbalance, you know,
a little bit lower and towards the
bottom, another selling imbalance. So,
they're not stacked neatly
on each other. And to be honest, if
you're just looking at a normal chart
like this, you might not notice it cuz
the markets are trading, you know, a lot
of stuff's happening very fast, you
might miss it.
But if you had software, right, that
will just highlight it to you say, "Hey,
you know what? You got multiple
imbalances in this bar." Then you'd just
take a sec second
look say, "Oh, yeah, I got
multiple selling imbalances. Market hits
the low, bounces back up. Now you got a
stacked buying imbalance in here."
Obviously,
this bar's got multiple imbalances
because of that stacked buying
imbalance. But then the next bar, right?
You might miss that if you're not paying
attention, right? But you've got
three buying imbalances in there.
They're spread out, but nevertheless,
they're in that bar
for you to see, to take advantage of,
right? Because,
you know, everyone is so focused on
stacked imbalances, but they're not
necessarily paying attention to multiple
imbalances. And that's what I'm talking
about having an edge in the market.
Multiple imbalances in a bar is just as
important as stacked imbalances in a
bar.
Okay. Here's another one. Market more or
less going sideways, you know, in here.
And then, you know, multiple selling
imbalances followed by multiple buying
imbalances. Markets go up. Markets start
going sideways.
Multiple imbalances, multiple
imbalances. Now this first one's got a
stacked selling imbalance.
Then this one's got more selling
imbalances, but this time it's spread
out. So what you you got two bars
together with a lot of selling
imbalances. Which way do you think the
market's going? Do you think it's still
going up? No. Chances are it's going to
sell off and it it drops nicely, you
know, over the next
3 minutes, it drops 10 points.
All right, it even goes down, you know,
another 10 points from there as well in
in the next 5 minutes.
Now here's gold, okay? So gold, you
know, is going up and then you get a
bar, some nice buying imbalances, okay?
But it doesn't go any higher.
All right, it starts turning in here. As
it turns to start going lower,
multiple selling imbalances in this bar.
Multiple selling imbalances in this bar.
Right? Market sells off, goes sideways a
little bit, then multiple selling
imbalances and market continues
lower. This was just this morning. It,
you know, 8:15 this morning in the gold.
Here's gold as well. We're coming into
the low, okay? Multiple selling
imbalances. It's what you expect to see
going into lows.
Then market starts ticking up. Multiple
buying imbalances. Multiple buying
imbalances. Now, this is where it gets
interesting because if you're just
looking for stacked imbalances, that's
nice. You can do that. But, you're going
to miss trades
like this. Right? This one came before
the bar with the stacked buying
imbalances.
So, imagine, where would you rather be
buying it? In here, off this bar,
buying it somewhere in here, or way up
here, you know, a buck and a half
higher?
Well, you want to buy it as as low as
possible, if you have a reason. And you
do
by looking at the bars with the multiple
buying imbalances.
This is 10 years, right? 10 years. Very
liquid market.
A lot of volume goes through in the 10
years. This is at 2:00 in the morning
yesterday, right? Off the low of the
day.
This red line is the low.
You got 1 2 3 buying imbalances. Now, 10
years, this is a four range chart, okay?
So, you're not going to get a whole
lot of stacked imbalances.
Right? This is a four range chart, so it
only covers five prices.
But, imagine,
three out of the five prices are buying
imbalances. What do you think that
market is talking to you? It's
screaming,
"Buy."
And the market puts in a nice little
rally up.
This is 10 years again. This is today.
This is this morning.
And this is why, you know, I talk about
having software that's going to help you
with your analysis is because you might
miss this, right? You might miss it as
it's happening in in real time. You
know, you you're seeing some bars with
some buying imbalances, selling
imbalances, but this bar right here in
the middle
it's got one, two, three buying
imbalances. All right, it's not hard to
miss if you know what to look for, but
if you got software that's going to help
you
highlight those that's just worth the
price of the software. You you take one
or two trades based off of this, it's
all worth it, right? It it adds value,
right? You only want to put things on
your chart that adds value to your
trading.
So
pay attention when imbalances appear,
but also put them in context of market
structure. You know, are buying
imbalances coming in, you know, as we
just made a low swing high or swing uh
sorry, a swing low or the low of the
day. Are selling imbalances coming in at
the high of the day? Are they coming in
just off the high of the day? You know,
as the market starts turning to go
lower, are the aggressive sellers coming
in? You know, those are questions you
always want to be asking yourself.
Put them in context, not just oh,
there's a bunch of buying imbalances
here, I got to get long. It's better
when you put it in context to the
market, you know, trade everything in
context.
So, the third part I want to talk about
is how to profit from understanding how
orders move market prices.
And that's really
what you want to do, right? Markets
present opportunities every day for
traders who know what to look for.
That's the key, knowing what to look for
because you could stare at a chart and
try and figure it out by yourself.
You might be able to do it, most likely
not. You're going to struggle.
That's why I like doing these trainings
is cuz I like to sort of, you know, get
people's thinking, you know, on on what
to look for. And I'm going to talk about
three things to look for.
And these are terms that I've coined
myself. One is delta flips, two is
stopping volume
three is delta pressure.
Excuse me.
And
delta flips.
Okay? So, remember Delta's a way to
measure the aggressive trading taking
place in a market, right? And basically
what I'm talking what Delta flips looks
for is
you know, where Delta was strong
but then
ended up weak or Delta was very weak and
then ended up strong, right? What in the
bar itself. I'm not talking about over a
half hour, you know, or anything like
I'm talking about right now, right? Cuz
these offer tremendous trading
opportunities.
And this is
soybeans. I hear people soybeans. I'm
going to trade soybeans. Actually,
soybeans is a fantastic market to trade.
You know, a lot of commodity markets
follow order flow
great.
Right? Because you don't have a lot of
hot money that you have in um
you know, a lot of the equities. You
know, there's a lot of other type of
trading that's going on where it's
commodities tend to follow order flow
better because they're really following
the supply and demand
um paradigm a lot closer because people
are buying it for to use, right? They're
people are going to make stuff with um
commodities, you know, whether it's, you
know, making
um
you know,
like for wheat for example, right?
They're going to make bread, things like
that. You know, oil, they're going to
make gasoline. And they're going to
refine it, things like that. People need
to use it.
And
you know, this market has been selling
off.
But there's something happening in the
order flow right in here
that's very bearish. And honestly, you
know, a lot of people will miss it.
And they're going to miss this move, the
sharp move down.
And forget about the rest of the move
here, but just this move from, you know,
76 down to
70 or even 75 down to 70, you know,
that's a $500 move.
Very fast.
All right. Again, you know,
a lot of traders, you know, nowadays,
you know, there's nothing sexy, there's
nothing glamorous about trading
soybeans.
But soybeans up until about, you know,
1998 probably made more millionaires out
of all the commodity markets than than
any other one, honestly. Um
so, when you're looking at the delta,
all right, what happened?
Okay, well, a couple things.
So, here, all right, you have this bar,
and again, they only talk about this in
the next a little bit later, but cuz
there's a lot of bearish information
happening in this bar. This bar has got
a positive delta of 179.
And it closed at minus 20,
the delta. Okay, so, it went from plus
179 to minus 20.
What's that telling you? Well, you had
very strong aggressive buying early in
the bar.
But the aggressive selling came in,
reversed all of that, and it closed
down. It closed negative delta, minus
20.
That's what we call a delta flip, where
it's strong in one direction early,
then
reverses,
and closes in the opposite direction.
Now, strong is a relative term. 179 is
this max delta.
You don't see any other bars anywhere
near it. I mean, this bar here had
positive delta of
155, so the 179 is still stronger than
the final delta. This one had a max
delta of 225.
But I know that 179 in soybeans
on a 1-minute chart is heavy.
All right, it's a strong number. So, to
see that reverse
is telling me, yeah,
you know what? Something's changed in
market sentiment right now.
I don't need to wait till the market
breaks down to start recognize I can see
that as this bar is
being formed and is completing.
So, I could be a ready in the next bar.
You'd be getting short around 76 and
1/2.
And then, you got the bar from 77 right
down to
73.
All right, the next bar goes lower.
That's what's called a delta flip. You
know, here's another example. This is
E-minis yesterday.
Market shoots up. Boom, you got this
nice, you know, shooting star type
pattern. But, look at the delta.
Positive 1,025. Delta closed at minus
36. So, not only did it go up a thousand
delta, but sold off another thousand.
And just closed at minus
96.
That's very bearish. I didn't see the
market
selling continued. Cuz it's very
Everyone's FOMOing in. Everyone's Oh,
we're making We're going in the other
the number's not so bad, you know,
inflation, who cares?
Everyone's buying.
But, then
you know, who knows? Maybe some of big
aggressive sellers came in and said, you
know, not on my watch.
And start pushing the market back down.
And the market dropped from, you know,
70 down to 60 over the next 1 2 3 4 5
minutes. These are 1-minute So, 1-minute
chart. So, basically, 5 minutes, dropped
10 points.
So, another example, high of the day
right here.
Okay, now there's other information in
the order flow. There's a divergence.
There's a bearish ratio.
But, really
if you're just looking at the delta, you
can see positive 708.
It's your highest max delta out of any
of these previous bars. You're at your
high of the day. Obviously, you want to
see a nice positive delta. Okay. Max
delta. Yeah, that's nice.
But, the final delta ended up at just
negative 128. So, it went from positive
and closed at just minus 100. So, it's
actually a shift from
plus
you know, it's a 800
value difference in the delta
to the downside.
And again, all you got to do is, okay,
well, you know, this moves over. Stick a
fork in it for now. Maybe later in the
day it may go back up, but who knows,
but for now, you know, the trade is to
the downside and you can see it's
dropped from 77 right down to 67.
Very methodically lower. Every bar's got
like a lower low, lower high. That's
what you want to see.
That's why I talk about sometimes these
things in the order flow is just so it's
so obvious to see.
Now, this was
very strong one here. This was in the
E-minis on the on the 13th.
Again, very strong.
Nice positive delta up 233.
It closed at minus 387. So, it went from
very strong positive to very strong
negative. Well, what do you think that's
telling you?
Well, not only was
you know, I was showing you examples
earlier where it just sort of closed
around neutral, you know, around zero.
Now, it's growing gone very um negative.
Quite strong. So, it went from a very
nice healthy positive 233 to a minus
387. You know, that's a change of 500,
almost 600 contracts in the delta from
positive to negative. All right? And you
get the market a little sell-off there.
Again, this one, all right? It's it
These things, right? You know, people
talk about the market being fractal,
right? You got this sort of the star.
You got the nice positive delta 948. It
closed at only at minus 139.
So, you know, it's a shift in 800
um delta
from plus 948 to only plus 139. Then,
obviously, the next bar, if you're not
convinced of this bar here, the next
bar, big negative delta
minus 662. But, you know, this bar
very similar to this bar.
All right? So, you know, these markets
what you're seeing a lot of times
it's
repeats itself. Right? Now, it's not
going to be exactly the same, but it's
close enough that you can
make good trading decisions.
So, the next thing I want to talk about
is stopping volume. All right? Volume
matters. I don't care what anybody says.
Volume does matter. Size matters.
Extra heavy volume matters even more.
It's just like eggs.
All right? You got eggs coming all in
different shapes and sizes.
All right? You you're cooking omelet,
right?
For yourself, you're going to use this
egg.
You use the quail egg.
You're going to be hungry, right? It's
it's not going to be enough. You use the
ostrich egg or the emu egg. Yeah, you
could feed the whole family.
So, volume matters, size matters. Size
is volume. Stopping volume, right? Is
what I'm talking about. And then what
stopping volume is, it's heavy volume
coming in at price.
This is the soybean chart that I showed
you earlier with sort of the shift in
the delta taking place. But, what do we
see here?
On the footprint, if you
you know, you I just drew this line here
because I know that I've got stopping
volume here. And when I have stopping
volume really what that's going to do is
it's going to stop the market from going
higher
or lower. In this case, it's stopping
the market from going higher. Market
doesn't come back to the 78 level.
Why? Because I can see the volume in
here, 187 on the offer. So, I know that
there's sellers in there.
If I know there's sellers in there
I'm not going to fight it. I'm going to
go in the direction
that they're selling in.
Or you know, or the direction they're
buying in.
This is 10 years. This is a 5-minute
chart, okay? And you can see the sort of
comes back up here. We got 1, 2, 3 point
of controls all sort of lined up. You do
have this
What is that? It's like 18 lots poked up
above, then it came in. And then
somebody basically put their foot down
on the market and said, "No, you're not
going to go any higher than this." And
you can see they're offering it, you
know, 1,800 traded on the offer. Even
here, 5,000 traded here on the offer.
Half the volume of this bar, this bar
has got 10,000 contracts, 10,000
870.
5,400
5,041 contracts traded on the offer
side. So, over half the volume of this
bar
traded on the offer up here. Basically,
somebody's saying, "No, I'm not going to
let you go higher."
This is 10 years on a four range chart.
And again, you know, it looks, you know,
it's a market that's going sideways.
But again, you're seeing the heavy
volume taking place just outside of this
little range. It's telling me there's
there's offers up in here.
All right? That this market isn't going
to go any higher.
This is in gold. All right? Volume is
relative, right? If you're looking at
gold, you're not going to get the same
volumes that you're going to see on 10
years.
You're definitely not going to get the
same volumes you see on E-minis.
It it it's relative. I But I know that
by watching the points of control in a
bar and where they appear,
if they're stopping volume, right? I can
see right up in here, stopping volume.
Point of control is up here at the top
of the bar.
Market reverses, starts selling off.
It's clear as day. It's like a sore
thumb sticking out there.
Stopping volume right down here. Again,
this is Euro currency. Right in here, I
can see. Now, this is something that's
unique to my software, is what we call
prominent point of controls, right?
Which is this uh I don't have it on
there, but I put it on on this one so
you can see it's blue. It's telling me
it's bullish stopping volume. So, if I
have a point of control, right? Every
bar has a point of control, the price
level on the bar with the most volume.
But if I see
a blue point of control, it's telling
me, you know what, they're stopping
volume to stop this move down.
Just as a red one here, well, it's
magenta actually, is telling me
they're stopping volume to the upside.
Right right in here. You can see the
market came off. So, all I got to do is
I just got to look for these blues
or magenta point of controls when they
come in. You know, here's another one.
Right up here at the high of the day,
stopping volume at the high of the day
to me is is one of the easiest trades to
take, okay? I know the market just hit
the high of the day.
Now I got stopping volume. What am I
going to do? Trade it to the short side
cuz I can't get long cuz I know there's
um
offers up there. I know there's there's
sellers up there, right? So, you got to
be trading it to the short side.
RTY, Russell, a very illiquid market at
times, but still you're going to see
stopping volume appear in these markets,
right? Market just
um you know,
doing what it's doing, not a lot of
volume. I mean, you could see in here a
lot of zeros appearing in these bars.
Then it just sort of stops in here and
almost instantly reverses.
So, you know, that's that's the simple
easiest thing, you know, let the
software do that for you. Let the
software highlight to you. You know,
I've talked about uh multiple
imbalances, right? Software can
highlight that to you. Stopping volume,
market can highlight it to you. Now,
delta flips something, you know, it's a
little bit more advanced that you got to
look for yourself.
And this next one I'm going to talk
about delta pressure is something you
also got to learn to look for
yourself. It's Basically, what it is
it's supportive buying or resistance
selling.
So, basically, when big traders step in
to take the other side of aggressive
buying or the aggressive selling and
create essentially support or resistance
in a moving market. And the way I like
to describe it, it's it's like the
tugboats, right? You got the big
freighter,
the sea going freighter, and generally,
you know, it's moving in a direction and
you got these little tugboats just to,
you know, give it a little bit of a
nudge, keep it going in that direction.
So, with with delta pressure, you know,
it's a market that's already going
say down, you know, and what you have is
you got um more selling coming in,
sort of adding, you know, overhead
resistance to it, just as if a market is
rallying, right? You're seeing
supportive buying coming in to keep that
move going up. Cuz if you don't have
supportive buying coming in on a move
going up,
it's not going to
keep going up because once those
aggressive sellers come in, it's just
going they're just going to drive it
down. But if you have supportive buying
holding up that market, even though you
got aggressive selling coming in,
they're absorbing that selling pressure.
Just as,
you know, if a market is going down, you
know, when markets go down, people like
to buy, buy the dip, right?
But if there's still
some nice passive selling people with
supply coming in there to sort of just
give the market, you know,
a little bit of resistance to absorb
whatever aggressive buying is coming in,
it's going to help keep that market
going down.
And this is, you know, this this is
slightly a little bit more advanced
concept for traders to understand, but
once you know what to look for, you
know, it it becomes clear as day.
Okay, so here, right? We got the market
selling off.
Negative deltas, right? Then the market
starts rallying.
Positive deltas. But look, you got green
bar, green bar, and you got negative
delta. Everyone is like, "Oh, Mike, you
told me earlier
markets go up on aggressive buying, they
go down on aggressive selling, they go
up on positive delta, they go down on
negative delta." Well, yeah, generally,
but delta is a little bit
multi-dimensional
because it's again, what does it
measure? It measures the difference of
aggressive buying and aggressive selling
in a bar.
So, if I got a market that's going up on
negative delta, it's telling me I got
supportive buying coming in here.
It's telling me that every time the
aggressive selling is coming in, there's
passive buyers coming in to absorb that.
Now, you still got the aggressive buying
coming in.
But, that aggressive selling is just
being scooped up
by the strong passive
buying that's taking place. That's why
you got the negative deltas in these two
bars.
Is because you got strong buyers bidding
this market to offering support to this
market. They're absorbing all that
selling until finally the sellers
shot all their bullets. They got nothing
left. And then all that's left is the
aggressive buying and then the market
shoots up very quickly, very fast.
Here's the market that's selling off,
right? You're selling off on positive
delta. Mike,
what is this? Order flow is a scam. No,
it's not. You know, you got to
understand what you're looking at and
start to put the pieces together.
You got positive delta on red bar, red
bar, red bar.
But, Mike, why is it going down?
Well, every time the aggressive buyers
step in,
you have
a passive sellers offering out their
supply to keep cuz, you know, the people
that would have the supply
generally got the deeper pockets,
generally have a better idea of what's
happening in the market. They're more
longer-term traders.
They're there to absorb whatever buying
because they they think this this market
still, you know, going lower.
So, they're happy to sell it at 4016.
They're happy to sell it at 4015.
They're happy to sell it at 4014. They
don't have to come in and
hit all the bids, even though they think
the market's going down,
because they know that, you know, at low
prices, generally you're going to get,
you know, potentially some some people
that are trying to buy. But if they got
a lot of supply and they think the
market's going down, they're happy to
sell it here at 16. They're happy to
sell it at 15. They're happy to sell it
at 14, 13, 12 as the market is dropping.
They don't have cuz they know that if
they come in
and start hitting all the bids
cuz they want to be short or they want
to be out of a position, the market's
going to drop further and it's going to
drop further faster. And they're just
going to screw shoot themselves in the
foot. They're going to bad execution on
the trade and they're going to lose more
money
because they could have sold it at a
better price.
Again, same thing here in the gold,
right? Going down on positive delta.
Look at this market drop from 17, 18
down to 17
um you know, 10.
All on positive delta. Why? Because
there's supply. People are distributing
their supply. You know, you know, with
Wyckoff and all that, people talk about
you know, the different phases,
accumulation, distribution. They always
talk about
distribution at at higher prices, not
necessarily at these low pri- at lows of
the day. But what you're seeing in the
order flow, you're seeing heavy volume.
Here's 100 contracts being traded on the
offer. Right? You're seeing, you know,
70, 80
you know, you're seeing 105, 124. All
the the volumes on the offer side is
much greater than the off the bid side.
So, that's what delta pressure is,
right? It's this
supply coming into the market to to you
know, keep the pressure on the market,
keep it going down. Or if the market is
going up to, you know, support the
market, right? To to absorb whatever
selling is coming in so the market can
go higher and and to this morning, great
example, right? We had the number
um earlier today. This is 10 years.
It's on a 1-minute chart and
you can just you you you start to get a
sense of, you know, what to expect from
the market based off of, you know, what
is happening
in the Delta. Okay, so you know, market
obviously shot up
then it starts
ticking down. Right? Down, down, down on
negative on positive Delta, right? Why
isn't it going down like here on
negative Delta? It's going down on
positive Delta, positive 425, positive
1100. Why? I got heavy volume up here.
That's people in here you know,
market just shot up. I can sell it, you
know. I'm happy to offer it out up here
at you know, 20
What is that? 25 and a half and again
here at 24, right? Cuz you know, they
think the market should be trading 20.
1575 here, 2300, 1100.
What's the volumes down here? The 27,
let me look at this. 1500 and you got
500, 500, 300, 700.
You got the supply coming in to stop
those moves and often times you're going
to see it happen with
um you know, stopping volume. You can
start putting these things together and
start to make sense. I mean, you don't
have to take every single thing I'm
talking about. Just look for one or two
things in the order flow. That's how you
become a better trader.
You start with
something that makes sense to you,
something that resonates with you. You
say, you know what? I understand why
that happens in the market. Then you
just you go from there. You build on it.
All right? There's that that saying, how
do you eat an elephant? Well, you eat it
one bite at a time. Same thing with
trading. There's a lot of different
aspects of the market that go into
trading.
Take the pieces that make sense to you
and build off of it.
Again, this is this morning, right?
Market What's the market doing? Well,
we're going up, right? Positive Deltas,
you got red bars here
with positive Delta. Well, it's telling
you there's supportive buying.
Okay? And you just look for these
things, right? Here, right in here,
right at this low.
Right, green bar up.
But,
you got strong negative delta.
It's your strongest negative delta
up to this point, on this chart at
least. It's minus
1,400.
What's a green bar up? I mean, what the
heck is going on? You've even got a
selling imbalance in here. Yeah.
Why do I got the big strong negative
delta? It's because I got strong buyers,
strong passive buyers. They're willing
to absorb whatever selling is going up
going on in this market to help keep the
market keep it support, so this market
can go higher,
which it does.
Okay? So, I mean, you you start to put
these things together, start to
understand them more,
right? But, you know, build off of, you
know, what reading the delta, reading
imbalances. I didn't spend much time on
point of controls, but point of controls
are also important.
So, hopefully, you know, over the last
45 minutes, 50 minutes or so, um you
know, I've covered a lot of ground, and
you hopefully you'll think it's time
well spent. I hope I think so, right?
Hopefully, you've learned a lot about
why and how the markets move. Now,
remember, this ain't brain surgery,
okay? It's trading. Sometimes people
want to make it more complicated than it
needs to be.
Stick to things that make sense to you,
right? We we we don't realize it, but
every day we're always trading.
Um you know, we go to a store,
and you know, if something is too
expensive in one store, you go, you
know, I'm not going to get that bag of
chips here, cuz I know I can go to this
other store and it's 50 cents cheaper.
All right, you'll do that. That's you're
making a trade in a sense.
Now,
I can't cover everything in a quick
training. I wish I could, but there's
really a lot about order flow, right?
Cuz it's so fascinating, and there's a
lot of little nuances.
But, I hope you have a good
understanding of the order flow basics,
things to look for in the order flow.
And if you're interested in learning
more, I got a very special deal for you,
right? You're going to be excited. It's
the Order Flows Trader 5.0. And
actually, well, I'm really excited
because in a couple of weeks, I'm going
to be releasing the new version of Order
Flows Trader. It's going to be Order
Flows
uh Trader 6.0.
And
there's some new features, but more
importantly, you know, for those of you
that like to automate things and and run
strategy analysis, you haven't been able
to do that on a footprint chart before.
With the Order Flows Trader 6, you're
going to be able to do that. So, you're
going to be able to take certain aspects
of the order flow like stopping volume,
um market exhaustion, things like that,
price rejection. You're going to be able
to analyze that with other forms of
technical analysis, and it's going to,
in my opinion, really a big leap
forward.
But really, what the Order Flows Trader
5.0 is it's like plugging a computer
into a Order Flows Trader's mind, right?
What they're going to look for, what's
happening in the market, so you're going
to make better trading decisions.
Now,
having software is one thing, right?
There's a lot of software out there.
Okay? But
just having good software is no
guarantee you're going to be successful
in trading. You still need some
education. And
the problem with a lot of software out
there, especially trading software, is
like you buy it and then there's no
documentation. There's no lessons on how
to really use it. They they sort of
okay, yeah, here's my software. You
know, they you see a couple of videos on
it, and it's just like
leave it to you to figure out how to
apply it.
I don't do that, right? I I want to give
you the good foundation, the good
education, so that you can be
successful. Right? Sometimes I I don't
even look at it as, you know,
being a software vendor. I like to think
of myself more as an education vendor.
You know, I want to give you that
education, so you can become a better
trader overall. And so, what I'm going
to throw in with the software is my
Order Flows Trading Course, which I
normally sell for $297.
It's a 20-lesson course. You know, this
was the first course on trading order
flow out there. A lot of people have
copied it. A lot of people go out there,
they copy my ideas and they they try to
push it off as their own. You know, I
mean,
I'm happy that people find value in in
what I'm doing, but you know,
a lot of the concepts that you see out
there, I was the first one to put them
out. That's why I started putting it out
because people were stealing my
concepts.
And also, to sweeten the deal even
further, I'm going to give you access to
my inner circle video series.
Which the only way you can get it now is
through getting the software. There's 56
videos on advanced order flow analysis,
tips, um you know, things to look for in
the order flow, etc.
Well, when I used to sell it, it was
about $500, but again, now it's it's not
available. It's only available for users
of my software.
So, you start adding that up together.
The software normally sell for $899, the
training is $297, the inner circle video
series is $497. That's almost $1,700.
But at the end of the day, I realized,
right?
Learning from
videos and books is one thing, right? It
takes discipline. Takes commitment on
your part. But what I found to be very
helpful
is a live training environment where you
can come in and ask questions. I'm there
every week,
unless you know, there's some major
holiday or some emergency. But for over
the last 3 years, I've been doing these
live sessions every Tuesday night and
it's open for all users of my software
to come in,
learn about um you know, what I saw
interesting in the order flow, ask
questions. All right? I like to make it
interactive. I probably spend
sometimes I spend the whole session just
answering questions and but usually it's
about half the session.
Um you know, where people say, "Hey, you
know, what do you think of this? Or what
do you think of that chart? You know,
can you take a look at this?" Or you
know, maybe they got question about the
software itself.
Right? It's there. It's a resource where
I'm there every week, you know, so you
know, sometimes people email, "Oh Mike,
I can never reach you." Well, I'm here
every week. All right, you can show up
there and ask me a question.
I think there's a hundred I haven't
updated this slide, but there's I think
over 170 episodes now. And again, if you
can't attend live, there's replays you
can watch. Right? And there's some
people they want to sell you software,
then they want to charge you extra on
how to use it.
What's that about? You know, that that
that this is the hell out of me. It's
like, you know what? I'm buying your
software, you know, you should provide
some training. But this is more than
just training on this you know, it's
just a place where you can go and learn
more about order flow.
Now, what I discussed today is just a
small sample of kind of analysis that I
talk about in in my weekly group
training sessions.
And you know, what can be found in the
inner circle video series. But I go into
much more detail in the live sessions.
All right, again, you're able to ask
questions. You're able to have
interaction with me.
So,
you know, I really
highly recommend you know, you guys get
it started now with with order flow.
Because you know, at the end of the day
you want to become a better trader and
there's there's no better way to become
a better trader than by using order
flow. So, what you want to do is you
want to go to orderflows.com/oft5
and
scroll down to the bottom of the page.
This is what the page looks like. You
just scroll down
and it's going to take you to
this button here. You're going to see
what you're going to get. You're going
to get the order flow software,
the trading courses, the live access to
the live group training.
You just click on this button buy now.
All right, takes you to PayPal. PayPal
processes your payment.
And you know, within a few hours you'll
get all your details. All right, you're
going to get your access to the
software, your license,
um
access to the training courses, etc.
Again, realize it does go you're paying
through PayPal, so you got to check your
PayPal the email address that you
used to log in to PayPal. Sometimes
um people forget about it because they
use a different PayPal address, but you
know, just check that one.
And it's just
the special offer is just a one-time
payment of $7.49.
Right? It's no monthly recurring
charges. I'm not one of these companies
out there that's going to keep charging
you every month and then it's like
you're going to forget about it. And I
don't charge you every year. It's just a
one-time payment. All future updates are
free. So, when we release the new
version
of OrderFlows Trader 6
by next month you're going to get that
upgrade for free. And
I'll be honest with you.
There's a lot of changes in this new
OrderFlows Trader 6
that actually the price of the software
is going to be increasing as well. So,
you know, now is the time to come in and
lock it in at this lower price
cuz you're going to get the upgrade for
free. So, go to orderflows.com/oft5.
I'll put the link in the chat.
But as an extra bonus for you guys today
for Investors Expo you're going to get
access to the OrderFlows Playbook, which
is a a short training course
on you know, sort of advanced order flow
techniques and and analysis. And there's
about uh 10, I think, or 11 additional
trade setups in there that you can learn
them to apply to your trading.
So, again, you want to get started now.
Go to orderflows.com/oft5.html.
And what you're going to get is you're
going to get the OrderFlows Trader 5.0
and the 6.0 when we release it
which is normally $899. You're going to
get the OrderFlows trading course, which
is normally $297. The access to the
inner circle video series, which is
normally $497. Access to the weekly
group training. Again, I I I I I I I I I
I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I I I I I I I I
But some people charge something very
similar to that. Uh they charge about
$200 a month.
You're going to get the Order Flows
Playbook as well, which is also 297.
But you can get it all of that for just
a one-time payment of 749. So, go to
orderflows.com/opt5
or you can just go to orderflows.com.
You could you know, that's my main
website.
But this is the special offer. I mean,
if you go to just orderflows.com, you
can you go around, you might end up
paying more
um than this special offer.
Now, I did write a book on trading.
That's how I started my software
company, actually, is I started writing
a book after I left JP Morgan on called
Trading Order Flow.
It's a 150-page book
and
you're not going to get the actual hard
cover copy. You'll get a digital
download.
So, just go to orderflows.com/book.html.
You'll have to enter your name and email
address, hit submit,
and then it will take you to that page.
But again, it's orderflows.com
/book.html.
It's just not orderflows.com/book.
You got to add the HTML on the end.
And that's it. So, just go to
orderflows.com/opt5.html.
And get started. I mean, it it's really,
you know,
the price that we charge for our
software and education is
it's it's a little bit, you know, it's
not a lot. You know, people like, "Oh,
you know, Michael, trading software is
so expensive. I can't afford it." Well,
if you can't afford 749 for trading
software,
how are you going to trade? You know,
right? Cuz it takes money to trade. And
you know, I I I just tell people, you
know,
just save your money, right? If you
know, this offer is something that
interests you,
but you can't afford it right now, just
come back in a few months. You know,
email me. Say, "Mike, you know, I
watched your presentation, you know,
is that can you still offer that price?"
And yeah, I I will. I'll still honor it.
Right? But I want to make sure you're in
a good spot financially before you start
trading. And remember, right? In the
end, we only regret regret the chances
we didn't take. You know, I know a lot
of people, right? When COVID hit, we got
shut down on everything. Everyone wanted
to start the trading, and you know, some
people got started. And now, that's all
they do is trade, right? They they don't
need to work anymore. They're they're
trading.
And then there's people like, "Yeah, you
know, I'm going to start this thing."
And then they never started it. And now
it's, you know,
2022 going on 2023, and they still
haven't started trading.
So, you know, at the end of the day, you
got you got to take that step forward,
right? And the first step is getting a
good base in trading, a good um
foundation in order flow.
So, anyway, guys, uh I'm just looking in
there. There's no questions, so I'll end
it there for today. So, have a great
rest of the day, and have a great rest
of the week. And again, thanks everyone
for taking the time out today. And I
hope you appreciated it. I know I had a
lot of fun.
So, thanks, everybody, and I'll catch
you guys later. Bye-bye.